with just two days to go before Iowa's
first-in-the-nation voting for the 2020
election the Democratic presidential
hopefuls are trying to make every second
count senator Elizabeth Warren made it
to a late night campaign event Friday
after leaving president Trump's
impeachment trial they'll spend the
weekend Criss crossing the state ahead
of Monday night's caucuses the latest
Monmouth University poll shows former
Vice President Joe Biden holding a
slight edge over senator Bernie Sanders
among likely caucus-goers ed O'Keefe is
in Coralville Iowa this morning at good
morning good morning Dan as a former
Iowa resident and I know occasional NFL
sideline reporter you can appreciate
that with the Super Bowl tomorrow and
many Iowans planning to root for
neighboring Kansas City Chiefs the
campaign's know that today is
essentially the last final full day of
campaigning and that's why those
senators were so eager to get back here
with Monday's caucus looming Joe Biden
and Peapod a judge crammed in seven
events between them on Friday every four
years everything begins here in Iowa
going on Monday evening and caucus for
us by late in the evening the four
senators running for president we're
making plans to head back out on the
trail in Iowa Biden in Buda jet had an
inner person who among us is most likely
to be able to defeat Donald Trump while
the Senators have been forced to
campaign from a distance add time to
make a final pitch I'm switching parties
to caucus for Elizabeth Warren and 2020
the ads are about unity but there's also
some infighting I've seen Vice President
Biden making the case that we cannot
afford to take a risk on somebody new
right now I believe in a time like this
the risk we cannot afford to take is to
turn to the same Washington mindset that
has brought us to this point the man not
competing in Iowa former New York Mayor
Mike Bloomberg is also making his case
on the air campaign spending reports
show Bloomberg has already spent more
than 140 million dollars on TV and
Internet advertising nationwide
Bloomberg has yet to appear on a debate
stage but that may soon change because
the Democratic National Committee has
now changed the rules in a way where he
could appear alongside his rivals by the
end of this month and Monday Democrats
here in the state are expecting record
turnout at the caucus Dana all right
thank you always an exciting time on the
caucus day there in Iowa and heard a ton
of ads from Mike Bloomberg was in
California this time if they're all
they're all over the place that was in
Kansas City California with you